what's going on reject nation thanks for
clicking on this video welcome to part
three of our reaction to zack snyder's
justice league if you missed part one or
part two
here's a card here to a playlist to
check out either one of those part two
is in the description box and pin
comment as
well this whole reaction is being cut up
into six parts so subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next one is up full length
movie watch along where you sync up with
the time code is over at our patreon
page and of course gotta thank eric over
at nerd chronic for editing these
reaction highlights for us
you rock buddy give him a follow anywho
on to
part thrus
here i'm so sorry i'm late
is this your first time meeting resume
from the french of course resume i
believe
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no finish that burger
[Music]
this whole thing looks like a graphic
novel it's like feels like it's framed
like a graphic novel
yeah yeah oh no zack snyder like he's
he's great at that
it's the first time they met
certainly looks like it the way this is
just communicating
oh
i love the choices soundtracks in this
that people on youtube probably can't
hear
yeah unfortunately all the moments that
we've muted
yep she's beautiful cool i'll save her
ooh hungry
[Laughter]
not get a bun some condiments
is truck driver okay
cool whoa
oh well now she knows barry allen's
flash
yeah she does
oh gosh i hope everyone's okay
oh my gosh right i start on monday
did you not have to play it off like
this
it's like i thought i just left
it's kind of weird that you're not
reacting at all
did you see that
oh damn that's okay so volkl was talking
about
do you have two thumbs or like
extra outside thumbs oh
wow it's amazing what a little blood
will do
ew
wait till the spider goes to work no
fairy little drone projector spider
thing
he must be an atlantean a water breather
he was breathing here when i talked to
him
i'm not sure we can trust him man if
we're gonna do this we're gonna need to
be open to more things that we have
meet cute
he's a cyborg
what are you some kind of cyborg
oh
was the football game in the bvs
ultimate edition in reference to a
victor stone football game that was
going on what do you guys tell me
well one thing's for sure zack snyder
should direct the football movie
that's the next one
get that down
break the plane
oh dad's on in the crowd
it's a college game they get their names
on the jerseys
bastard
typical silas stone he got held up with
the lab
star labs or skynet he wanted to be here
you're cute chuck season terminator
oh everything i know you can do today
i can't wait to see what you're gonna
beat along
no
i won't let you die
all right look
you don't have to give me a second
chance but give yourself one
try listening
how dare they cut those scenes out of
the movie
like damn that actually
angered me that those were not in the
other cut
no firewall can stop you no encryption
can defy you
we're all at your mercy [ __ ]
the fate of the world will literally
rest in your hands
it's an entire nuclear arsenal you could
launch
with a doesn't that thought
fun victor
wow the world's monetary systems and its
complex interactions will seem as easy
for you as a child's plaything
is the burden of this responsibility
that will define you
and who you choose to be
oh all that money oh golly
yep i can never be cyborg
just skim a little bit on the top of
every bank account on earth no one will
know
wow you can see anyone's like life story
like that
who robin hood
let me speak to you from my heart not as
a scientist
oh [ __ ] i think victor is just still mad
about the football game
i don't care that i'm a cyborg you know
why where's your at my football all
things considered this is a great power
but you never care about football
currently
i know you have abilities i just don't
know what they are
competitive ice dancing it's what they
use on the space shuttle to prevent it
from burning up on re-entry
i do very competitive
whoever you're looking for it's not me
there it is
[Music]
wait a minute i know that symbol
batman you see i believe enemies are
coming stop right there
i'm in you are can i keep this what are
your superpowers again
i'm rich
this like this movie's like actually
building
you are not alone they've had this like
it's there's a real build to it oh it's
so cool
oh this prince let me do that
i forget i'm actually a butler stuff
never happens here
cool cool a gauntlet that captures and
dissipates energy
it's master wayne's idea maybe you
should work on a lasso too
in black of course
something is not working
something is not working
you know who i am i know more than you
can possibly imagine
then maybe you already know i need your
help
the world does [ __ ] the world
we need you victor and maybe you need us
i don't need anyone i told myself the
same for a long time
but i had to learn to open back up again
and if you ask to meet me
you're working on it too
oh
i feel like turning off all the lights
would have made more people come outside
people are
screaming
what's going on out there
the inner core of the metal becomes
super heated you're looking at the
hottest thing on earth
exact words i said to my prom date she
dumped me anyway
yeah you tell me this story every day
ryan
commissioner gordon oh yeah that's right
police academy what's wrong with dental
school
yeah he's got this film noir talk i'll
talk to him tonight
oh jim how do you think
let me use the giant light on the roof
floodlight that i've been using for 20
years
you know it's easily visible across it
you must be very i'm diana hi very i'm
diana
oh awesome that's the bat signal that's
your
oh sorry it's your signal that means we
have to go now
yeah that's that's what that means it's
so cool
[Music]
i like that they kept it someplace high
but that's underwater
that's true i told the king the
perimeter guards were taken
he won't send reinforcements he says all
the reserves are needed in the rebel
regions
all right take what men we have left and
for my phalanx around the motherboard
british accent yes she does definitely
not in the aquaman movie
which they said was supposed to be a
sequel to this version
so either way i'm sure everyone's happy
to see her
that is creepy
oh
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
let me swim past that
ah
[Music]
hexagons
you must be author kerry
[Laughter]
atlantis the first born of beloved queen
atlanta
it is like a full-on birthday it is
i kind of like it better i do i think it
works better
my dad ran out on me and he took the
window
oh well it's gonna draw some attention
yep the end of part three people thanks
for watching
if part four is out there's a there
should be a card
if there's not a card it's not out yet
either way subscribe click that
notification bell hit the like button
leave your thoughts down below
and just just keep a look out or click
i don't know what point in time you're
watching this so can't tell